- The FBI raided Trump's
house in Mar-a-Lago.
Well, the FBI executed a search warrant
and took a bunch of documents and things.
But yes, this is unprecedented in America.
Yes, it could be the beginning
of a criminal prosecution
of the former president.
Yes, it could be the tip of the spear
of a political witch hunt
by the Biden administration
against a political rival.
Or it could be a mundane effort
to retrieve archival documents
that leads to absolutely nothing else.
We just don't know.
- The FBI, and I give them a lot of credit
because they're fighting forces
that they're not supposed to be fighting.
- But what do we know
about the search warrant
that was carried out against
former President Trump?
We can't make many
assumptions about the FBI raid
until we see the actual warrant or until,
you know, we see an indictment.
But here's what we do know.
The Justice Department is conducting
at least two investigations
that we know of into Trump.
The DOJ is looking at his
attempt to overturn the result
of the 2020 presidential election
and is also investigating
the alleged mishandling
of classified records.
The National Archive is
charged with collecting
and sorting presidential material.
The National Archives has publicly stated
that it had to recover at least 15 boxes
of White House records that Trump took
to his Mar-a-Lago resort.
The records include some
classified material.
And we know that Trump has a history
of destroying and withholding records.
He was repeatedly warned
about destroying documents,
but according to CNN, "Politico,"
and "The Washington Post,"
he tore them up and threw them
in the trash or on the floor.
White House officials reassembled
some of those records with tape.
The National Archives confirmed
that the Trump administration
sent the archives
some documents that had
been taped back together
as well as records that
were still in shreds.
I'll be doing a separate video
on the Presidential Records Act
and the implications of the Espionage Act,
but multiple sources told
CNN that in April and May,
the FBI interviewed
Trump's Mar-a-Lago aides,
and in June of 2022,
investigators visited Mar-a-Lago
to discuss Trump's removal
of potentially classified material
that had been taken to
the Florida property.
One of those investigators, Jay Bratt,
is the chief of the Counterintelligence
and Export Control Section
at the Justice Department.
Trump reportedly greeted the investigators
but did not answer questions.
The investigators asked to see
where the documents were being stored.
Trump's lawyers showed
them a room in the basement
where boxes of records were being stored.
Some reports said that
the documents were marked
with TOP SECRET.
On June 8th, the
investigators sent a letter
to Trump's lawyers telling
them to secure the room
where the secret documents were stored.
Trump aides complied with the request
and added a padlock to the door.
Now, I probably don't need to
tell you just how insane it is
that there could be top-secret
classified documents
being stored in some
basement in Mar-a-Lago
or just how insane it is that
the FBI raided Mar-a-Lago
potentially over these documents.
But I do have to say that
"they even broke into my safe"
is probably going to go down
as a quote for the ages.
But the search began early Monday morning
and apparently focused
on the area of the club
where Trump's offices and
personal quarters are located.
The investigators met with
two of Trump's attorneys
and Trump reportedly
greeted the investigators
but did not answer questions.
Investigators removed more
than a dozen boxes of items.
Eric Trump told Fox News
that he was told, quote,
"the purpose of the raid,
from what they said,
was because the National
Archives wanted to, you know,
corroborate whether or not
Donald Trump had any documents
in his possession."
Trump's lawyer, Christina Bobb,
said the FBI seized documents
and Trump cooperated with the FBI.
Quote: "President Trump and his legal team
have been cooperative with
the FBI and DOJ officials
every step of the way.
The FBI did conduct an unannounced
raid and seized paper."
Although Bobb said the
raid was unannounced,
CNN reported the FBI and
Secret Service communicated
about the raid before it happened
to ensure that it went smoothly.
Donald Trump was in New
York on the day of the raid,
and the Biden administration
was reportedly not aware
of the raid, according to CNN.
Now, we can assume this
raid did not happen
at the behest of a rogue FBI agent
or a local judge acting without buy-in
or notification of
high-level DOJ officials.
Obviously serving a warrant
on a former president
is an incredibly serious
thing, and it's a decision
that can't be taken lightly.
The FBI and DOJ must follow constitutional
and statutory requirements
for obtaining a warrant,
which we'll talk about in a moment,
but in addition, the DOJ has guidelines
for investigations of political targets.
In 2020, former attorney
general William Barr
issued a controversial memorandum
stating that anyone in
the Justice Department
who was investigating a
political candidate must run it
by the attorney general for approval,
and current attorney
general Merrick Garland
renewed that memo on May 25th, 2022.
Garland's memo is titled
"Election Year Sensitivities."
The memo reminded DOJ employees
of the department's long-standing policy
for avoiding steps that could
be perceived as partisan
and designed to influence
an election result.
Quote: "This is particularly
important in an election year.
Now that the 2022 election
season is upon us,
and as in prior election cycles,
I am using this memorandum
to remind you of the
department's existing policies
with respect to political activities."
Now, Barr's original
memo says investigations,
including preliminary
ones, into presidential
or vice presidential
candidates, their campaigns,
or staff cannot be opened
without the written approval
of the attorney general.
It also states that an investigation
into a congressional candidate
or campaign cannot be opened
without first notifying the
assistant attorney general
and the respective US attorney
in the district involved,
and if an investigation is initiated
in line with these guidelines,
then the investigating agency
has to provide regular updates
to the deputy attorney general.
Now, Trump has indicated
that he will be a candidate
for president in 2022.
So the TL;DR version here
is that the FBI would not have applied
for a search warrant
without Garland's consent,
and presumably, they also
would've gotten approval
from the Trump-appointed FBI
director, Christopher Wray.
But what is the requirement
for a federal search warrant?
Well, a search warrant
authorizes law enforcement
to search a location for
any of the following:
evidence of a crime,
contraband, fruits of crime,
or other items illegally possessed,
property designed for
use, intended for use,
or used in committing a crime,
or a person to be arrested
or a person who is unlawfully restrained.
Now, usually those first
three are lumped together.
Imagine a simple burglary
where jewelry was stolen.
You'd want to look at the burglar's house
for the stolen jewelry,
cash or drugs that might have been traded
for the stolen jewelry, or burglary tools.
And so law enforcement has to
identify two different things:
one, the person or
property to be searched,
and two, the items to be seized.
Now, more to the point,
law enforcement has to
establish probable cause
to believe that the
items to be seized exist
and will be located in the person
or property to be identified,
and probable cause is hard to define.
It's imprecise, fluid, and
very dependent on context.
The US Supreme Court says that finding
whether probable cause exists is, quote,
"a practical, common-sense
decision whether,
given all the circumstances,
there is a fair probability
that contraband or evidence
of a crime will be found
in a particular place."
And what does fair
probability actually mean?
Well, it doesn't have a
specific number attached to it,
unlike the standard of
preponderance of the evidence,
which is just a hair over 50% or more.
That said, several
studies over the decades
that involved surveys of
judges generally agree
that probable cause is somewhere
in the high 40s but beneath 50%.
And it might be worth noting
that some jurisdictions,
like Oregon, have collapsed
the probable cause standard
and the preponderance standard
so that probable cause means
anything over 50% likelihood.
But that is not the federal
or constitutional standard.
The constitutional standard
is only a fair probability.
Then you might ask,
how specific does a federal
search warrant have to be?
Well, generally speaking,
not that specific.
We can look to the search
warrant that was used
against Paul Manafort.
It includes something
very specific, quote,
"a Bijan Black Titanium Royal Way watch,"
but it also includes
general categories of items,
like "any and all financial
records for Paul Manafort, Jr."
Now, we'll get into what
that means in practice later,
but let's talk about the practice
for getting a federal search warrant.
Now, the applicant for a search warrant
is generally a federal law
enforcement officer of some kind,
an FBI agent, a Treasury agent, et cetera,
and as of 2016, federal agencies employed
about 132,000 full-time
law enforcement officers.
And every federal search
warrant is reviewed
by an assistant US attorney of some kind.
Now, that's not required by
law, but it's a policy decision
by the Department of Justice.
Now, the application itself
is a one-page template,
and federal law enforcement
generally attaches
three documents to that application.
The first is the affidavit
by the investigating officer,
attachment A includes the
property to be searched,
and attachment B lists
the items to be seized.
Now, the affidavit is a sworn declaration
by the law enforcement
officer that sets forth
the officer's knowledge
of the investigation.
It can include hearsay
and even information
from anonymous or confidential sources,
though the officer needs to establish
the reliability of that information.
The purpose of that affidavit
is to establish probable cause
to the reviewing magistrate.
But the affidavit is all there is.
The magistrate does not get to consider
any additional information,
just what's contained
within the four corners of that document.
Now, that said, the magistrate judge
has to issue the warrant
if there is probable cause.
It's not optional.
The judge does not have discretion to say,
"Well, there is probably probable cause,
but I don't think you need
it for your investigation.
It's looking pretty good on its own."
Once the magistrate judge
has found probable cause,
the warrant must issue.
And what this means in practice
is that the magistrate
judge signs the application,
the one-page template, and
issues it to another officer
authorized to execute it.
The warrant must be
executed within 14 days
and during the daytime,
unless there's good cause
to execute it at some other time.
And this should go without saying,
but I'm gonna say it again anyway:
Just because a judge signs
off on it doesn't mean
a crime has been committed,
and just because you have
received a federal search warrant
doesn't mean that you are a criminal
or have done really anything wrong,
see contra all of the
legal bad takes on Twitter.
And as a reminder,
just because a search warrant was executed
on a particular person's
property, that doesn't mean
that particular person is the
target of an investigation.
Now, it is very common
for that to be the case,
but search warrants are frequently served
on Google and Meta for
information and data
that they keep on their servers
that are relevant to an investigation.
They're not the target
of that investigation.
Now, it's rare, but occasionally,
search warrants are executed on members
of the media who have
information or lawyers
who represent the targets
of an investigation.
Nor does it mean there
absolutely will be a prosecution.
Just because there is
probable cause doesn't mean
that the government can prove a case
beyond a reasonable doubt in a jury trial.
That's a completely separate consideration
in light of all the evidence,
including whatever evidence comes out
as a result of the search warrant.
The beyond-a-reasonable-doubt
standard is much,
much higher than the probable cause
or even the preponderance
of the evidence standard,
though it's always good to remind people
that just because you aren't convicted
beyond a reasonable doubt doesn't mean
you didn't commit a crime also.
You know, so it goes both ways.
Now, there are some
differences between state
and federal courts when it
comes to search warrants.
For one, the states don't have
a single uniform procedure
like the federal courts do.
Now, they all basically
get you to the same place,
but they certainly won't look as uniform
as they do in the federal system.
And state judges have a reputation
for rubber-stamping applications
for search warrants.
The federal system has
the Department of Justice
that acts as a gatekeeper
for search warrants,
even though that's not
required by federal law,
so state judges are more
likely to get warrants
that contain plenty of
grammatical and formatting issues
and might not have quite as much evidence
as far as probable cause goes.
But in any event, the end result
is that officers will
show up to a location,
knocking on the door,
notifying the people inside
of the search warrant, and
then searching the scene.
That means getting
everyone out of the place
so that they can't tamper with
evidence or present a threat.
The officers then search
the place in accordance
with what's allowed in the warrant.
They can search for the items authorized
by the warrant and open any containers
that could reasonably contain the items,
including safes, lockboxes, and the like.
And using the Paul Manafort
search warrant as an example,
we saw that there was
a pretty big category,
"any and all financial records
for Paul Manafort, Jr."
So let's say that you're one
of the FBI agents on the scene.
You would basically look
for documents and papers.
And let's say that you
find a manila folder
that contains 100 or so pages.
You might skim through it, and as you do,
you see a couple of financial records
that pertain to Paul Manafort.
You would then likely seize
the entire manila folder.
There are two reasons for this.
One, people typically
keep financial records
with other financial
records or related records
and those related records
might be needed to make sense
of the specific financial
records that they're kept with,
and second, you don't
have time at the scene
to fully understand how all
the documents link together.
In other words, you don't
understand the import
of those documents at the scene.
So you'd probably take
the entire manila folder
and notate on an inventory form something
like "manila folder
containing financial documents
located in the lower-right-hand
desk drawer in the office."
Now, agents keep an inventory
of what items they seize
and where they found those items.
They are required by law to do this.
When they're done executing
the search warrant,
they will leave a copy
of the search warrant
as well as a copy of the
inventory of things seized.
Now, it's important to note
they do not leave a copy
of the affidavit.
All they will leave is
the one-page application,
along with the two attachments
listing the property
to be searched and the items to be seized.
After that, the investigating officers
would then return the search
warrant to the magistrate,
and it would specify the date and time
the warrant was executed
and include the inventory of items seized.
So what's next?
Well, Trump has a copy
of the search warrant
but not the supporting affidavit.
He could release it if he chose to.
There's no legal reason
why he couldn't release it,
and it's interesting that
he has chosen not to.
And additionally, there are
reports of a mole or informant
inside of Mar-a-Lago, which
might explain the exigency
of the FBI's search of Mar-a-Lago.
Additionally, "The Florida Times-Union,"
Judicial Watch, and "The New York Times"
have filed a motion to unseal the records.
The supporting affidavit is sealed
to protect the
investigation, and generally,
the DOJ doesn't comment
on ongoing investigations
because it could jeopardize
the investigation
and tip off other targets
or the target who is the initial target.
- [French Narrator] 12 seconds later.
- Except, of course, when the DOJ chooses
that it's going to make a statement
about an ongoing investigation,
like when you're trying to get
a friggin' YouTube video out
and the attorney general for
the United States chooses
to give a press confidence. (yells)
Attorney general Merrick Garland confirmed
in a press conference that indeed,
he did have personal supervision
over the search warrant that was executed
over the former president's
estate at Mar-a-Lago.
And in fact, because
former President Trump
did confirm the search
warrant was executed
and publicly stated information about it,
the DOJ is going to move
to unseal the records
related to the search warrant itself.
One gets the sense that the DOJ was trying
to keep this quiet, and in
fact, this comes on the heels
of a report from "The New York Times"
that a subpoena was issued
against former President Trump
to return some or all of
the documents in question
and that may have not been complied with,
which might have forced the DOJ's hand
to execute a search warrant
to get these documents.
And now we're facing the
incredibly interesting situation
where it's the DOJ that is moving
to disclose this information
and it may be former President Trump
who doesn't want it disclosed.
He, of course, always had the ability
to disclose the receipt
and the other pages
of the warrant other than
the probable cause affidavit,
and now he may be in a situation
where he wants to keep that secret.
But at least that's likely
to be the last bombshell
that we have to deal with
in this particular case for a while.
- [French Narrator] 12 seconds later.
- Are you freaking kidding me?
So "The Washington Post" is now reporting
that the documents at issue
here concern nuclear weapons,
which explains a whole lot
about why this search
warrant was executed,
why the exigent circumstances,
and why everyone is freaking out.
It also throws a huge curveball
in the people that were saying
that the president could
just declassify documents
on the way out of the White House.
When it comes to nuclear
weapons-related documents, often,
that has to go through a
separate regulatory agency.
Often, the president is in
charge of declassification,
but when it comes to
these kinds of documents,
that is not necessarily the case.
It also raises all kinds of questions
as to why former President
Trump took these documents
out of the White House and
why he might have refused
to turn them back over when
multiple requests were made,
which is what has been alleged.
So we'll cover all of the
potential criminal implications
of this in a separate video,
but this whole situation is
raising all kinds of questions.
But one thing is for sure:
Keeping a bunch of classified documents
in a basement would be
a pretty stupid move,
but they could quickly
get their brains back
to functioning correctly
with a logic or math course
from today's sponsor, Brilliant.
Brilliant is an online
learning platform for STEM
that replaces lecture videos
with hands-on interactive lessons.
Brilliant is for curious
learners both young and old,
professional and inexperienced.
You could quickly learn
to ace your high school
or college math courses
or just learn stuff you always wanted to.
One of my favorite courses
is all about logic.
Brilliant's logic courses
cover liar and truth-teller riddles,
logical fallacies, machine logic,
and even some strategic game theory,
and logic is a crucial skill that lawyers
and former presidents need every day.
Brilliant's statistics and finance classes
are also extraordinary.
Now, Brilliant lets you learn by doing
rather than just listening
to hours of boring lectures.
Learning through doing
is scientifically proven
to be the most effective
way to master any new skill.
The courses have storytelling,
interactive challenges,
and problems to solve.
So you can sign up and start
learning today for free
by clicking on the link
that's onscreen right now
or in the description.
The first 200 people to sign up
will also get 20% off
their annual subscriptions.
So by clicking on the link that's onscreen
or in the description,
you'll get 20% off your
subscription to Brilliant,
plus clicking on the link
really helps out this channel.
And after that, click on this
playlist for more LegalEagle,
or I'll see you in court.